CBS News contributor Bob Schieffer was
chief Washington correspondent and
hosted Face the Nation for 24 years he's
covered nine presidents including one
who was impeached and another who
resigned he's with us from Washington
Bob good morning always good to see you
Thank You Nora how are you I'm well I'm
well let's start with what the president
said in Paris he said most people would
have taken such a meeting with a Russian
lawyer after a set of emails like that I
think most people would not that is most
people who know how things work who have
been around Washington for example who
know what the Russians are doing in
other parts of the world trying to sow
disinformation here's what I would have
done if someone called me and said hey
the Russian government wants you to know
that we want to help in this campaign
and we've got some dirty stuff on your
opponent and we want to get together and
tell you all about it you know what I
would have done I probably would have
laughed first but the second thing I
would have done is I would have said are
these people trying to set me up are
they trying to draw me into something so
they can get something on me and and
then turn it on me later to their
advantage I say that Nora because I've
had people who have tried to set me up
over the past I mean you know I've
always said news is where you find it so
I've talked to some pretty unsavory
characters in my time but I always go
into it wondering and making sure that
that I know what this is about and if it
had been someone from a foreign
government I can tell you for sure that
even as a reporter I would have been
very wary about that and and probably
would not have done it at least until I
knew more about what was going on there
a lot of the signs point to Jared
Kushner who hasn't been in many of these
meetings and you see major Garrett's
reporting now that he has had to amend
his federal disclosure form to get the
security clearance three times first
thing he had no meetings with foreign
officials and now it's over a hundred
names of foreign contacts well you know
these things where you bring family into
government never never seemed to work
out quite right I've known people up on
Capitol Hill who would install their
wives as the chief
staff and then you realize you can't
fire your wife you'll realize that the
staff can't come and tell you criticize
the wife if she's done something wrong
it just never seems to work out I'm sure
these young men are very smart and very
intelligent but you don't know it just
because your daddy owns an airplane
doesn't mean you know everything about
everything there are some things that
you probably need a little help to check
on and so forth so I I think the whole
idea of trying to run the presidency
like of like a family grocery store I
don't think that works very well most
people's daddies do not own airplanes
it's great to see you it's beyond it let
me ask you a question about something I
was struck by Ted Cruz earlier in the
week said that from his vantage point no
one in Texas is talking about Russia
we've got three Texans in this
conversation right now so let me ask you
is anyone in Texas talking about Russia
I think they are and I think there are
people in a lot of places that are
talking about Russia but I also will
tell you there is that core of maybe 30
35 % of Trump supporters who probably
would much rather talk about something
else and and we'll stick to him too to
the very end so yeah I think there are
people that are not talking about it but
I also think there are people who are
can we ask you before you go about the
visit to France that just took place
beyond the continuing fascinating body
language between the president and the
French president others in these
handshakes and other things there are
the issues here and it does seem like
the president and and the French
president have found some common ground
on terrorism issues anti-terrorism
issues and then there's the question of
whether the president might find room on
climate change or immigration after
dealing with with Emmanuel macron what
what do you make of that relationship
and where it might go in the future well
I hope I hope it gets better I would
like to see our relations with all our
traditional allies get better I mean
when you look at what the Russians are
doing now
and how they have sewn this discord how
they are going into these Central
European countries they don't have to
drive their tanks across the border
anymore they go in they bribed local
officials they make sweetheart deals
with the rich people there to build
things they found a better way to do
this and they're doing it actively and
Putin's objective is to break NATO apart
and to separate us from our NATO allies
and you have to say right now he
probably has a smile on his face so I
hope there is a rewarming of relations
between the United States and France Bob
Schieffer thank you again good to see
you thanks